beep all right let's do the usual audio
sync thing okay one packet okay 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8
all right look we're both doing the
thing where we got clear on our throat
so let's take a second really
[Music]
well this has been planned for quite a
while now but I decided now was the best
time to do it
can you guess what time it is dear David
oh yeah yes the biggest oldest had ever
existed what are your thoughts boy this
has been a long time coming because this
is very important to the series you know
actually you mean I've said this earlier
but the first time that we ever started
this was when I sent Savior a bunch of
bad examples of Rob Liefeld comic art
one time and we had fun roasting them
and hey we're doing it for YouTube now
so it's fun and I'm excited to finally
honor one of the be information for this
great series that's right David this is
going to be a great one I've saved up a
lot of bad ones just for this occasion
for those who don't know Rob Liefeld is
a comic artist from the 90s who was well
known for his stylish Lee sloppy art
work he was one of the leading factors
of the comics crash in the 90s where
everything became more about making the
books look cool and less about them
being written well his original
characters are all stereotypes of that
edgy muscular badass with a bandana
around his head and a shiny robot arm to
hold up his rocket launcher and they can
usually be found standing around in
dirty inner-city alleyways surrounded by
ankle-high garbage
he drew almost every major Marvel comic
at one point or another and I
accidentally found a lot of his art
meaning all the art today was gathered
by myself fan suggested art will come
back next episode whenever next episode
comes out I can see in six months or
whatever but I got to tell you picking
just 5 images to rip apart for this
episode with no easy task so that's why
there's 15 between all the sharp jaw
lines artificially obstructed feet
grotesquely muscular characters barrel
chested hairy men giant impractical
weapons shoulder pads women with broken
spines and legs longer than this
sentence squeaky faces far apart eyes
strategically placed shadows to avoid
drawing faces awkward midair poses
blatant reuse designs and characters
spiking nineties haircuts
for perspective cluttered group shops
improbable Arsenal's derpy facial
expressions and lazily drawn props
I could barely decide what to pick but
thankfully I managed to bring together a
few that I thought really demonstrated
why he's famously infamous so both from
my own travels in the land of comics as
well as some classics that everyone
online loves to hate our first image
here is a horribly proportion Captain
America no not that one a different one
because there is so many taps hands are
big enough to wrap around his entire
head and he's apparently a Simpsons
character being that he only has three
fingers to each hand his size are
comparable in life to his arms making me
wonder what kind of lanky hellish
abomination he would appear as if he
just was in a standing position and
let's not forget Scarlet Witch down here
with her stylish headpiece I think if
she looked down too quickly she'd slit
her own throat with that thing I'm glad
you mentioned Scarlet Witch because it
to me her headdress looks like she took
a bucket shoved it over her head got
stuck and then she just sort of cut out
her cut out a hole for her face and
split with it I mean that's what it
looks like to me it looks like a plastic
bead like a he-man character I mean it
looks like Captain America's body has
been stretched and rolled out by one of
those taffy rolling machines you know
one of them how else would explain the
hideously awful proportions of his body
also I wanted on record that Captain
America's eyeballs look painted on I
just love how everyone except that one
guy on the right in the bottom panel has
the exact same face they all look like
like like they're standing in a wind
tunnel and their cheeks are baby blown
out all right let's move on to another
favorite of mine it's a dizzying assault
on one's natural sense of perspective
I'd like to know how much of an effort
was put into making sure everyone's feet
couldn't be seen unless it was
absolutely necessary this fellow up here
has an interesting Anatomy with what
appears to be a knee behind the back of
his leg
and a curved stance that would make him
look like a torso balanced on two
bananas in the front though he at least
doesn't have to deal with the
elephantitis that cable has from the
waist down then some childbearing hips
speaking of hips take a gander over at
this mushy rubbery piece of [ __ ] up here
that vaguely resembles Spider Man or
more athlete Piderman at least I can go
to bed at night knowing I can
objectively draw a better Spider Man
than Rob Liefeld that Spider Man kinda
looks like he has the proportions of a
dog the proportionate legs and fine of a
dog exactly
and any pranks of a spider I wonder what
juggernaut sees on the ground that makes
him angry enough to grit his 343,000
front teeth down at the ground and stare
directly downward with such intensity
that his brows are furrowed somehow
behind his giant impractical metal mask
maybe not a copy of x-men 3 the last
hand oh the jungle [ __ ] like he looks
pissed off through that like I bet I
completely ignored that when I was going
through this because I was just looking
at how like messed up Spiderman was back
there anything else asked me like metal
or something the mask yes it's so that
Professor X can't do the mind thing on
him so I just remember that episode of
x-men evolution where they had to try
and get off the helmet on I'm thinking
that looks like a salad bowl hey if you
think you have
speaking of salad bowls let's go to a
bad Rock ah bad Rock such a classic
character with such memorable
catchphrases at West Rock dirt bags and
yabba-dabba-doo meeee
let us note first that his fingers are
sicker than this woman's thighs what a
man
the 18-foot circumference of his tree
stump thighs legs is entirely surrounded
by pouches large enough to seat or a
human child so at that point they're not
even really pouches and have ascended to
just being [ __ ] backpacks
I'd also like to ask you a question
David where the hell does
face connect to his torso the punchbowl
of a lower jaw doesn't go anywhere he's
just sitting there
balanced the top his mountain his texts
I don't know maybe maybe he's connected
there with one of those smokestacks he's
got on his back you know this really
makes me wonder how sex works between
Rob Liefeld men and Rob Liefeld women he
says like you can see his pinky is
bigger than her her leg so how do they
procreate bad Rock is he laid the
troubled existence um he cannot
procreate for he would explode them also
you notice she's not wearing like pants
what's something that I've noticed a lot
in Rob Liefeld women they were like
stockings that look like they're being
held on just by the pouches around their
thighs the pouches are really tight okay
just just don't don't put them on too
tight because they'll cut off your
circulation
well David there's no way we can only
talk about five images and end this
episode before we get to the last two
big ones let's do something I like to
call why felt my fuel side bonus
lightning round
whoo ready we're going to run through
these as fast as possible I'm going to
start and then you do the next one all
right begin we are connected via
satellite with Tess Harlow snn News
correspondent coming to us live from the
local news too far corn dog convention
giving us the four one one on this
epidemic of blade spell chicken legs
attacking the blind so john test did you
put your hand in the grease fryer again
i was originally going to talk about the
incongruity who in the fact that the guy
on the bottom is disposed supposed to be
kicking the other guy backwards with his
foot but then i was distracted by the
guy in the purple suits is love to its
products and i just got to thinking
about how you see so many creases in
that guy's musculature that you think
they must be born into these suits
because how do they get some off at
night hey when you think of spider-man
what comes to mind first lazy half ass
crosshatch lines are a pink and pale
blue color team play off the cigarettes
juggernaut [ __ ] lay out the Twinkie
go straight your cab good god Peter did
you put both of your hands in the grease
fire too okay where do you buy your
nondescript skin tight boob hugging
hoodies it fit perfectly on your
successful shaped torso and matching
skin types of pants my headings have
been disappointingly useful and
practical I'm asking for a friend Sonny
hey buck Bob is recycling designs again
I can't believe it's not Deadpool who
does your hair
I've always wanted a mullet the length
of a lion's mane with padawan braid
somehow squeezed into a face guard
shaped out of a wicker chair and how do
you manage not to get your luxurious
hair Scott and all the armor that's
wrapped around you the life jacket is
very fashionable though Hey look Rob's
recycling designs again I can't believe
it's not cables here we need a character
affectionately named cord hey buddy
listen I think you might have had a
might have a problem I think you've had
too many plastic surgery jobs over the
past year you need to settle down and
lay off the Botox for a week or so
you'll never look normal again but at
least you won't get weirder whoa
Deadpool what's the nard ruined cables
favorite pair of mom jeans way to add
insult to injury after this guy just
went down on she venom can you decide
who has better medical bills the women
was there horribly mangled spine or bad
rock with his dental surgery to make his
jaw less of a teaspoon I don't know but
good old ladle face here has got biceps
for days why are we here
suffer here I'll throw a curveball with
this one there's no way we can keep the
three sentence rule with this [ __ ] Wow
a whole panel learns my mind if this one
comes from Youngblood and it makes me
nauseous to look at from the shiny color
hundreds of cascading curvy shapes
sitting in close proximity look we've
got cases of hidden feet leg proportion
problems broken back discussing
washboard abs carrot feet absurdly bulgy
characters barrel chest and tiny heads
it's basically a collage of all the
things he doesn't know how to do how
long do you think it takes to get a
Robert Liefeld character dressed it must
take at least an hour and several tons
of Vaseline to get these characters into
those skin tight onesies and at least
two hours to strap all the pockets on
just so they can keep those things up I
keep their [ __ ] bus change in there
and then now must be it must be pretty
painful for characters like troll who
are covered in body hair now if we could
take a brief intermission for me to
answer the phone
I'm so sad sit down goddamnit
okay fine I guess I have to go and get
up get my house phone but by the time I
definitely longer audience I guess it's
just me now yeah so
how would you feel if I just killed
Savior and take over his channel I'm
asking for your head Lee hey you excited
for that new Wolverine movie that looks
pretty cool please subscribe to Davidian
productions I need subscribers ok my
phone's ringing now cuz he's calling me
that's great so I guess I just gonna
have both phone conversations it mine's
pretty good how you doing no not not
that good but you know I'm the other
phone yet
you guys want to talk to each other I'll
hold the phone together like that
spider-man book hey it was a Tuesday
let's say it was a Tuesday
wait Ernie mom did you hang up okay Wow
Oh God I didn't expect this to work
alright what's what's up that dang it
Godzilla Mendoza just who no find Ida
I'd settle for four chubby for dinner
what do you think alright that sounds
fine I'll totally take that how about
that mom what am I doing with my life
chubbies alright cool great I'm glad
leading them to this all right I'm not
even here alright I hope I god we don't
even know another annual cordon lines
about pieces of art medical people who
way more successful in welding on my
white Oh everyone's up David David I was
originally intending that to be funny
but then it just came out now I'm sad
which is Deus know what a fantastic time
for my internet to break down oh hey
you're back cardinally you didn't stop
recording right no I just had a nice
chat with your audience oh that's great
well you know what while I was well as
soon as the internet disconnected I got
a call from both of my parents at the
same time on two different phones and
then had to do a whole thing
well what the way comics are written
David having the author described the
action in the panel and the amount of
characters in it as well as the dialogue
I can't help but imagine Rob getting a 9
paragraph summary for this page and
replying with a stern [ __ ] as his
backwards baseball cap falls off and he
spills his box of x-men pogs you got a
feel for the guy because the writer
behind this image isn't doing his job
either and he has no idea how the flow
of a scene works in comics this layout
was a visual assault from conception but
then I remember Rob wrote Youngblood -
so [ __ ] it well it's time to cut the pig
off double whammy ha ha well it's time
to cover the big one David are you ready
what is arguably Rob Liefeld's most
popular piece this one belongs in museum
if I could get this painted and put on
my wall in my basement I would do that
because I'm a hipster piece of [ __ ] and
I would have it there ironically now
Captain America's chest / truth far
enough forward that he could rest a
dinner plate on his pecs he could set a
book there hell he could use it as a gun
rack
cap storage efficiency and entertainment
convenience aside he had to make some
sacrifices to the perfect male figure
and he is very clearly flat down there
from all the roids his belt buckle also
appears to be indented into his flesh
because it has no dimensions and sits in
a perfect line with a 3-foot long crotch
region is it just me or do I see a
little bit of like Rob Liefeld in the
jaw here like you ever notice that Rob
draws himself all the time I feel like
you carry himself into this I think this
is how Rob Liefeld sees himself or would
like to see himself one day this is the
man he aspires to be yes I'd like to
think that at least it's a little bit of
fun I like to imagine that Rob himself
has a giant framed version of this photo
in somewhere
house in its right hand exercise
equipment so he can get some inspiration
when he needs it mom he's just going at
it on the treadmill going I'll be like
Steve one day I just need to keep doing
enough squat now never skip leg day do
nothing but leg day also I'd like to
draw attention to a couple of smaller
details you might need to check his
under his pecs as well because they seem
to me a couple of lumps there might be
cancer and finally the star on his chest
is horrific Lee lopsided are you sure
you put your suit right on I mean I know
it takes a better part of the day and
but you'd probably need to make it right
like his shirt is just crooked and
that's white well hold on why is it why
is the star facing towards the audience
what the [ __ ] is happening with his
chest like again I've seen countless
diagrams and x-ray views drawn to
express just how silly this is the fact
that Rob proudly signed his name on this
is astonishing the fact that everyone
else working on the book at the time saw
this colored it in formatted it printed
it and sold it is absurd
not one person along the chain of
command told him this is weird looking
guy this guy career is still going he
keeps doing cover art and he's always
talking about relaunching his old series
for no reason in particular and all I
can say is that's great Rob Liefeld
radical tubular extreme nonsenses is joy
to mock he's a genius at being bad and
he should be celebrated I compare his
artwork to the works of such master
filmmakers as James Nguyen Neal Breen
and lenka Basinski yes it's got flaws
out the wazoo but how many laughs have
been had it talking about it picking it
apart I hope this guy draw comics
forever not comics with characters that
I like but you know what I mean and hey
let's be honest we get all mock and
point fingers and laugh all we want but
Liefeld's rolling in cash and living it
up while his most famous acts
dentally cool thing rakes in money from
comic sales and movie tickets that's
right I owe Rob Liefeld a lot since he
created one of my all-time favorite
characters and he's even the biggest
contributing factors of the creation of
this series you're watching now dear
audience so cut the guy a break would ya
I mean poke fun at his drawings all you
want but the man himself isn't so bad no
I do agree with that from a certain
point of view I think that laughing at
Rob Liefeld comic art has given me hours
and hours of pleasure and it has given
me so much material as a comedian and
without it we wouldn't have a job
I get it I like ironically said bad
stuff - I like troll - I like Batman and
Robin
but you have to draw the line somewhere
and that line is when Rob Liefeld gets a
seven-figure movie deal that's right
this past January Rob Liefeld signed a
deal signing off the rights to his was
it awesome comics lined yep and Akiva
Goldsman writer producer of such epic
masterpieces as Winter's Tale
Batman and Robin - The Da Vinci Code and
I Robot has been signed on to be a
writer producer on this epic cinematic
universe that's right they intend to
launch a cinematic universe based on his
idiocy and if you don't think that this
may spell the end of comic book movies
as we know it you're crazy
oh boy you can't can't you wait for for
uh the avenge alene is already getting a
movie directed by Akiva Goldsman
what about war child or blood wolf but
with a you there they're going to be
part of the cinematic universe like the
the edgy 90's Avengers oh god I hope we
get a fighting American movie
yeah this is fighting American in his
main nemesis what's-his-name is it Red
Skull probably black skull black skull
oh so it's like that guy in Arkham
origins who is just the Joker all right
yeah Rob's gonna kind of ruin movies
soon but you still gotta admit he's a
better writer than Dan Slott ah boy I'm
gonna get some angry comments for that
one see you next time folks I don't know
who you're talking about so bye
and don't worry we've got plenty more
where that came from
see you next time